next week  on the bachelorette  the path we're on right now it doesn't  end well  for anybody i just waited so long for  this  okay you've just blown up the  bachelorette  this is hard claire's gone and  i still haven't like fully comprehended  what the hell is going on  what about me just tell me that's all i  want to know  this is a two-way street doesn't seem to  make sense to me right now  you can tell that guys are getting  drained and fed up  you're gonna start seeing a different  side of me it's frustrating as hell i'm  gonna freak  out we put ourselves on the line like we  did everything you asked  i'll apologize if i wasted your time  i'll apologize if i hurt you  why am i here everything  crumbled in an instant what the  just happened we have never dealt with  anything like this  in the history of our show i mean i'm  confused as all hell  what is next  the bachelorette on a special night next  thursday on abc